The biggest AI delivery vehicle
in Microsoft is Office 365.
With a total of 150 million
monthly active users,
it's really a key part of
everyday AI, we are working on.
So I'm gonna invite my colleague
Rob to come up to show
you some cool features,
what we do with AI in Office.
Rob?
>> Thank you, Harry.
Hi, everybody.
I'm Rob Howard, I work in the
Office product marketing team.
And I'm really excited to be
here today to talk to you about
the AI powered tools we're
adding to Office to help people
do their best work.
Now, truth is, we've actually
used AI in Office for
many years.
You can think of features like,
spell check and flash fill, and
recommended charts that are a
standard part of the Office you
know and love.
But with the advent of Office
365, when we took the cloud and
deeply integrated it with
all the apps across Office,
it really accelerated
our progress in AI.
And as Office 365 has grown,
it's become one of our
biggest vehicles for
delivering Microsoft AI
technology to real people.
And helping them get
real value out of it.
You'll see how we're using that
world data, user data, and
especially, work data to
help save people time,
to help them focus on the things
that matter most to them.
Even help them be
better writers and
unlock hidden insights
in their data.
I'm gonna start off by showing
you four of by favorite AI
powered features in Office.
These are features
that I use every day.
And you may have seen some of
them, but like any good AI,
they've gotten better as
more people have used them.
And I wanna share
with you the latest.
And then, I'm gonna show you
four new ways we're bringing
AI into Office in
the coming months.
So let's get started here in
the latest version of PowerPoint
available as part of my
Office 365 subscription.
I'm working on
a presentation for
the Contoso Mark 8 quadcopter.
And I will tell you,
I've spent most of my
career as an engineer.
So actually building
impactful presentations
takes more time and
effort than I'd like.
And just a second
to come back up.
So building impactful
presentations takes me a lot
of time and effort, and
frankly, design skills
that I just don't have.
Luckily, that's where
designer come in.
Designer lets me focus on
the content of my presentation.
And it takes care of creating
a beautiful representation of my
ideas, so that it's as impactful
on my audience as possible.
I'll show you what I mean,
I'm gonna start here
on the title slide.
You can see it's
a little bit boring, but
I have a few images that
could spruce them up.
And I'm gonna drop
them into the slide.
And normally, I'd start
rearranging them, cropping them,
resizing them to create
a layout that I was happy with.
But designer is always working
for me in the background, and
when I add that content to the
slide, it automatically pops up
for me with advice on
how to lay them out.
And as I click though them,
you'll see it is creating
these beautiful designs that
are featuring the content
I've added to the slide.
And it seems really simple,
because designer
made it that way.
There's actually a lot of really
incredible stuff going on here,
things like salient
region detection and
facial recognition,
and color analysis.
So you'll see that even
as it's cropping and
resizing these images to
build a beautiful layout,
it understands that the hand and
the quad copter are the central
point of the image, and it keeps
them at the center even as it
crops it for the mobile phone
and the remote control.
And as it finds the dark in the
electronics and the mountains
and the blues in the sky on the
water, it's able to echo those
in the design of the slide
through color analysis.
If I go to the next slide,
you'll see I have a pretty long
image here with a lot going on
or a lot of different faces,
there's this guy's
yellow jacket.
It will be really easy as
Cortana's pulling out a square
image from it, for
it to just take the center or
the left side.
But it's actually able to
recognize the one in focus face
in that image.
And as I page through the
designs that Cortana chosen for
me, you can see it's making the
face, the hero of that image.
And I told you these
are getting smarter, and
one of the ways that designers
getting smarter is it can deal
with more types of content.
So not just images,
but now texts.
As I go to the next slide,
you'll see a set of
development milestones.
Now designer is using natural
language processing to
understand that this is actually
a timeline, a series of months.
And it's able to create for me a
beautiful representation of that
timeline that really makes the
milestones pop for my audience.
Or I can go to this next
slide where I've got
a sequence of steps.
And Designer recognizes
that as well, and let's me
create a quick sequence diagram
that clearly outlines the flow.
And it's even able to do things,
like pull out the verbs from
these steps and
use them as a quick header.
So I've seen how in a few
seconds, I can use AI to help
me create a more impactful
presentation in PowerPoint.
Now we're gonna switch into
Word and see three more of my
favorite AI powered
features already in Office.
We're gonna start with another
AI powered assistant Editor.
Now Editor goes way
beyond the spelling and
grammar checking
that you're used to.
It actually takes into
account machine learning,
natural language processing, an
extensive and ongoing input from
human linguists to actually
make me a better writer.
If I scroll down
in this document,
you'll see a bunch of examples
of gold dotted underlines.
And if I drill into them,
you'll see that Editor can
catch everything from
overused clichés,
like think outside the box,
to jargon like headhunting, and
even potential bias,
like young blood.
And for each of this, it not
only detects the problem but
it suggests a solution like
maybe using a new people instead
of young blood.
And if I'm interested
in learning more about
that recommendation, I can drill
in to see more and get a lot of
detail about its recommendation,
as well as other examples.
And I can customize
the way that Editor works.
So if I really feel like,
I wanna hold on to my vague
adjectives and my Oxford commas,
I can do that in order to
preserve my personal style.
Now you've seen a couple of
examples of how AI is helping me
create better work, but
AI can also help me work more
naturally along the way.
One thing we see people do a lot
of is print off documents like
these and then take a pen and
write comments in the margin or
mark them up with edits.
And this sounds kind of silly,
but it sort of makes sense.
It feels really
natural to use a pen,
and recent research has shown
us that actually using a pen
activates your brain more
deeply than using a mouse and
keyboard, especially when
absorbing information.
But with AI and
Ink Editor in Word,
we can actually make using
a digital pen and ink fill as
much as paper, just without
all the printing and scanning.
So I can do things like,
choose a red pen.
And of course,
I can write in the margin.
But this pen is actually better
than a real pen, in that I can
make edits with it, like
striking through this sentence.
And those edits
are automatically affected in
the document.
I can even go and change to
a highlighter, an Ink Editor
understands that I no longer
want to strike something out but
add emphasis to it.
And I can use gestures like
a circle or a scribble,
And Ink Editor understands
exactly what I intended.
So I've done my editing.
Actually, I wanna
add a little bit more
content to this document.
You'll see I need to go get
a project milestone table and
a forecast chart.
And I know that these are things
my colleagues were working on in
other documents.
So normally, what I'd do
here is I'd leave Word.
I'd go into another tool
like Outlook or OneDrive, or
SharePoint to go and
search for that information.
Once I finally
found the document,
I will go drill through it and
a find a table that I needed or
the chart I was looking for.
I copy that out, I come back
to Word and I insert it.
It really break up
the flow of my work.
But with a new AI powered
feature in Word called Tap,
I can directly within
the flow of my work,
in the tool I'm already using,
take advantage of all of my
organization's knowledge in
order to find the right content.
You'll see that I
can do things now,
like filter down to
specific content type.
So I'm looking for
this milestone table,
I can choose tables.
And the first thing
that comes up, or
on the first list that come up,
is this fabric cam case study,
where I know the project
milestone are.
And when I drill in you'll
see that it's not the entire
document.
It's actually breaking down the
specific elements that I might
wanna reuse.
And here I see that
project milestone table,
that I can add to my
document in a single tap.
And because it's still
a full featured table,
I can style it to look good
in this particular document.
Now this cash flow forecast
chart didn't show up as one of
the top items.
Well, that's okay because tab is
actually tied into personalized
search powered by OneDrive and
SharePoint.
So that when I type in forecast,
I'm gonna get results
that I have access to and
ones that are most meaningful
and relevant to me.
So you'll see that
the Casheville
forecast is actually
the top item here.
I can drill in and again,
find that chart,
add it to my document.
And because it's a full
featured chart inside of Word,
I can do things like add
a trend line, again,
without having to leave
the flow of my work.
So now I've shown you my four
favorite AI-powered features
already in Office.
I'm gonna switch to
what's coming next.
And we're actually gonna
start inside of Excel.
Now if there's one thing
we've learnt from our work
in AI is that data is
an incredibly valuable resource.
And with hundreds of millions of
people using Excel there's a lot
of data in Excel spreadsheets.
A lot of the data looks like
this, it's a simple table but
there's a lot of columns, teams,
categories, type, line items.
And I don't, looking at it, get
a sense of how this data works.
What are the trends?
What are the ways that these
different categories and
columns affect the values?
And I could, of course,
use all the tools in Excel
to go create charts and
pivot tables to analyze it
in a lot of different ways.
But that would take me a lot of
time, even as an Excel expert.
But with Insights, which is
coming to Office Insiders this
month, I have an AI powered
assistant that will do all that
leg work for me.
So I can run Insights on
this particular data set and
really quickly get
a sense of how it works.
I can see things like
spend increases over time.
I can see that if I break
down this data by type,
payroll has a significantly
higher spend than anything else.
And if I drill into more
insights, I can see deeper
things like if I isolate
just stock compensation.
I can see a really
significant outlier,
and I might wanna drill
into that further.
So I'm gonna hit insert chart
and insights will actually
automatically create a pivot
table for me in Excel and
tie to this data showing
me this exact insight.
I can mouse over here and
I can see the outlier
occurred on September 2013.
But I really wanna understand
the source of that so I can use
Excel's functionality and pivot
tables to break it down by team.
And immediately I can find
that the engineering team is
responsible for
that outlier and I can go and
investigate further.
So in just a few seconds, I was
able to understand this data set
and find a few key insights that
I may wanna investigate further.
All right, now we're gonna
switch gears to things are truly
bleeding edge.
And in fact, so leading edge
that I'm gonna connect to
a devsmachine in Dublin in
order to show it to you.
Earlier, we saw how in TAP I can
use organizational knowledge
in order to more quickly
access what I need and
incorporate it into my own work.
Now we're gonna see how
Word Online can connect to that
in order to help you understand
your company better.
That organizational knowledge
can be a barrier in addition
to a help.
I know at companies
like Microsoft,
like probably every
large company,
it can sometimes feel like
we have our own language,
especially when it
comes to acronyms.
When you move teams or
work with different groups,
it can be a barrier
to understanding.
And we're now connecting Word
Online deeply with the Microsoft
graph and
the work knowledge that it has.
So that when I open a document
like this, Word Online can use
that knowledge, pulling from the
emails that I have access to and
the documents I have access to,
to automatically identify
acronyms in the document.
And then within the tool
I'm already using,
identify them for me.
So I can see AINR means
Artificial Intelligence and
Research, and
that it was found from my email.
Where I can see things like NPS
means Net Promoter Score and
it's founded from files
that I have access to
in my organization.
If I have one of these that I
still don't quite understand,
I see BPO means
Business Planning and
Organization but
what exactly is that?
I can even see exactly the
source of the information and
get an excerpt to understand
that Business Planning and
Operation is actually
a team at Microsoft.
So now I'm gonna show you
my last two demos and
they're both in Outlook.
Outlook and recent features
inside of Outlook like
Focus Inbox, has done a lot of
work to help me spend less time
managing my inbox and more time
focusing on what matters to me.
And soon, Outlook is gonna help
me do that within an email.
If I open up this email here,
you'll see its gotta
a lot of texts.
But we're actually gonna use
natural language processing to
identify the action items
in this text automatically.
Open up the email.
So I've got a quick
video that I can show
you on this one instead,
like I told you this is bleeding
edge stuff that is coming soon.
There we go,
it actually popped in.
Sorry about that.
So you can see that as I'm
looking through this email we're
using natural language
processing on
the email to identify the action
items in it automatically.
So you can see
the underlines under,
did you see the update
the partner sent us?
And if I mouse over one
of these action items,
you can see see it's providing
suggested responses, and
these aren't canned responses.
It's not just yes, no, maybe,
it said did you see
the partner sent us?
And the responses are things
like, yeah I saw it, or
no what was it.
So it's tailored to
the specific action item.
And when I say,
know what was it, Outlook
automatically creates a reply,
it quotes that action item, and
it inserts my reply
directly in line.
And I can do that throughout
the entire email,
responding to each of
these action items, so
I can really quickly make sure
I'm covering all the action
items and
respond to them even on the go.
The last feature I wanna show
you is in Outlook Mobile.
And I have [LAUGH] a feeling
that this feature was built
exactly for me.
Anybody who works with you,
will tell me that I am
a perpetually late person.
I have a tendency to schedule
meetings back to back.
I don't really take into
account how much time it will
take me to travel between them.
And it often happens that by the
time the Outlook Reminder shows
up to tell me I need to
be there in 15 minutes,
it is gonna take me way too
long to get across town.
Luckily Outlook and Cortana will
soon solve that problem for me.
You can see that Cortana is
giving me a notification, that I
need to leave by 5:05 to arrive
on time for dinner with friends.
And it's telling me it's
gonna take me 24 minutes
to get to the Lake House based
on my current position and
my current traffic conditions,
so I know I'm not late.
I can even force-touch into
that notification, so I can see
a route to the destination that
I'm going to and deep-link into
my favorite mapping
applications to get directions.
So as a quick lap around all
of the AI infused features in
Office but really, that's
just a drop in the bucket.
We've been hard at work, adding
AI to Office for years and
there are literally dozens of
features that are AI powered.
You'll see things like quick
started and researcher.
You'll see things
like my analytics,
ink to math, ink to shape, one
of my favorites, Math Assistant.
If you come over to the booth
we'll tell all about the full
story of Office and AI.
So thank you very much.